[Music]  I'm still in Panama Malibu shooting for  GTA what's the best thing you say to me  it has to be something funny has to make  me laugh  one way or another it can be crude it  can be light-hearted it doesn't matter  just has to be the best pick-up line  I've ever heard  Emily Freeman are Kelly some you must be  a football coach the way you got me  playing the field  the best technique to learn about a  guy's personality would be watching him  in a emergency situation high-intensity  it has to be some kind of big deal and  watching them how they deal with  [Music]  subjects to never bring up on a first  date I don't think there's anything that  you can't bring up I think everything  free-for-all  [Music]  you  you